Hey traders, it's Mike here, and happy
Memorial Day. It's not only Memorial Day
in the US, but it's like the the spring
bank holiday in the UK, so markets are
very quiet. And you know, over the
weekend, there was uh reports coming out
that we are making uh progress towards
uh some sort of peaceful resolution in
the Middle East. And as a result, you
know, a lot of traders
were expecting the markets to uh go
higher, which they did. And you know,
more importantly,
for us uh that drive cars, uh look for
the crude oil market to drop. And it did
uh drop nicely. We're trading around
9140. It's about 9:00 in the morning
Central Time right now. Um you know, the
stock market is closed. And even though
futures are open, it's just going to be
that abbreviated session. Um you know,
but with that said, you know, while it
is uh not only a US holiday, but a a UK
holiday, you know, a lot of traders are
enjoying the the nice weather here in
the in the US. I don't know what it's
like in the UK. Um you know, people
always ask, you know, can we trade? You
know, well, of course you can, but you
got to realize there's there's got to be
it's not a lot of opportunities simply
because the volatility is down. Now,
again, you know, if you were
uh you know, sort of watching the
developments in the Middle East, you can
see what was uh on the table for when we
did reopen. And we reopened and we
rallied. Um and you know, we're all the
way up What was our high in the S&P?
7568.75.
You know, it would be it would have been
a lot more interesting, I think, uh
if it wasn't a holiday weekend and and
then the reports reports over the
weekend are starting to come would come
out that saying you know, there is uh
probably a peaceful resolution. Um I I
think this market might be uh
turbocharged uh if if more traders were
uh following the market. But that said,
um
can you have traded this market? Again,
you know,
you got to pick your battles, all right?
Yes, I know there's there's news,
market-moving news that is coming out.
Um and there the market is probably
going to have some nice movements. But
you got to remember, it is a holiday
weekend. Even though we're going to get
movements, the volume is going to be
lighter,
um and as a result, maybe the the moves
might be a a little bit lighter, as
well, or or they could be even more
exaggerated based off of the lack of
volume. So,
you know, I've been talking for the last
couple of weeks about our order flow
entry model. Let's uh
add
the exhaustion
to our footprint chart and just sort of
see, you know, if there was anything
interesting happening in the order flow
in terms of the exhaustion in the
markets. Now, granted, again, you know,
I'm I'm not trying to dissuade you or
anything, but, you know, volume is
lighter. It is a holiday, not only in
the US, but in the UK. And as a result,
that is going to affect um the movements
in the market. And just really quick
here, about 8 uh just before 8:20, you
got a nice bullish signal here. Here's
your entry. We look at that, we even
came right back to
the same level, doesn't stop you out,
and you get a nice move up. There's one
that just happened pretty recent here.
Um
you know, here's your entry, here's your
stop. This one sort of came back up,
tagged your stop, you know, started
going down, and it just sort of hanging
around, hanging around for about 10
minutes. Um
that's what it's like on quiet days, you
know, on on holidays. It's not that, you
know, it's a holiday that the market's
not open, you can't trade. You you can,
but, you know,
the spots are going to be limited. Um
you know, here was a trade potentially,
but not doesn't get you in because part
of the entry model is one of these next
two bars has to go higher than the high
here. So, that's no trade.
Uh let's just scroll back. We don't need
to go all the way back to the open.
You know, here's one at 4:00 in the
morning.
Small one. But, this is
symbolic of
a holiday, right? You got a small move
here. Okay, before it shoots back up.
Right? The moves are going to be
a lot smaller and
probably shorter duration.
Um here's a couple small trades.
Again, yeah, did these work out? Yeah,
you got in, doesn't stop you out, it
goes up here, just sort of hangs around
here for the next 7 8 minutes. Again,
similar thing, gets you in here and it
just hangs around there before it comes
down and stops you out.
Uh let's just go back here. Oh, this was
a nice one. Couple here. This first one,
this is about 2:00 in the morning
Chicago time. This one doesn't get you
in, even though here's your exhaustion
print here, right? If you had gotten in,
you'd get in here, but it doesn't trade
there, so you're not in. But if you did,
you would have been stopped out. You
know, that's why I say part of the entry
model is letting the market get you in,
right? If this this is our entry bar
right here. If this next bar
or the bar afterwards doesn't trade
above the high of the signal bar,
there's no trade. So, that's no trade.
It's a beautiful one here right on this
low.
Okay.
That's your entry, getting in right
there. And this is a nice move from, you
know, whatever that is, around 51
all the way up into the 60s before it
just sort of pulls back here and goes
sideways, but that was a nice uh trade
of about 10 points. You know, and just
really quick talk about sort of the the
other aspects of the trade.
You got the big red bar right here,
okay? Remember, right?
This whole entry model is called the
exhaustion entry model.
So,
it's a reversal signal. And when you get
a bar like this, like this big red bar
here,
all right, look at the volume, 2300
88. This is at 2:00 in the morning
Chicago time, 2:00 about 2:19.
>> [sighs]
>> A big move quickly. Again, it's a move
from about 57 down to about 49.
Huge negative delta minus 640. You know,
relative I say huge is relative to we
look at the previous bars.
You know, in the 30s.
You know, this is 23 79. You know, the
only other big deltas is 113 and 101.
And
this move exhausts this market.
Sellers are exhausted by the time they
get down to this low. I mean, it hits
this low right here.
Bounces up.
Sellers come back in and they're just
they're just tired. They can't sell
anymore. You get your exhaustion print
here. Three, the deltas very strong
negative delta 640.
Then just seven and then just 34. Then
it turns positive. Aggressive buyers are
coming in. You see a buying imbalance
right here. Another buying imbalance
coming in there. So, not only do we know
that the sellers were exhausted on this
move down.
We could tell that in a couple ways.
You know, obviously one is the
exhaustion print and two is the delta is
decreased from
you know, minus 600 to just minus seven.
Then, you know, to minus 34. So, there's
not strong
delta selling anymore. Meaning strong
aggressive sellers. Then, obviously the
delta turns positive.
Then you see the obviously the
aggressive buyers coming in here
with the buying imbalances, you know,
which also signifies buying.
And we get a nice, you know, over a
10-point move back up. Now,
let's talk about crude for a second here
cuz crude, you know, crude's been very
volatile obviously the last couple of
months. Um
you know, anytime it's above 100, I I
you do notice that
volatility, you know, the price
movements are much or much more
magnified when crude's over for
Um but we gap down, you know, from about
$97
dollars
>> [snorts]
>> to like uh 90 So, it's like a $3 gap
right here. Okay?
Yeah, and then gap traders, you know,
they're waiting all this time. You know,
this is
This is where we open. You know,
everyone is waiting for us to fill the
gap, right? You know, gap traders. Well,
it it it hasn't come back up there,
right? So, there's no trade
to be had
yet because we're we're nowhere near the
filling the gap. We haven't even taken
out our high since we've opened. Our
high was on the open. And it's by thin
volume as well.
Um but
when we uh take a look at the footprint
here, okay? Let me just make sure I got
my template loaded, my exhaustion
template.
Okay.
Uh then we'll just sort of go through
um the exhaustion signals here in crude.
So, you know, we're just turned 9:00
here. Let's see if there's any signals,
okay?
There's a couple I can see a few signals
coming in here, but this was one just
around 6:53 this morning.
>> [snorts]
>> Again, this is the same template that I
had using on the S&P's.
And our deltas, again, you know, this is
a thinner market. You mean, look at
these volumes. 35, 29, 71, 104. Volumes
increasing a little bit. Um but deltas
pretty consistent. -11, -1, -11, -10.
But here's your exhaustion print right
here. Next bar trades above. Got your
entry right there. You're talking
around, you know, this is uh 90.70. Gets
all the way up into This is 91 bucks
right here.
So, you know, anywhere in here
opportunity to get out. You know, it's a
25-cent
trade right there. Never even
never even went against you.
Um
Let's see these other trades. Here's
another long right here.
This is about
uh 5:19 this morning. Again, you got
some nice selling coming in here. It's a
nice drop from
your exhaustion print here and here sort
of back-to-back. Now, this is
interesting. We'll talk about this one
first.
This this was the move that we reversed
off of.
So, here's your exhaustion print, okay,
the first one right here.
Okay. You know, they say let the market
take you in.
Because your stop is going to be right
about the high of the exhaustion print.
So, this bar opened up. It's a red
candle, okay?
Traded up cuz it was a green candle
early
before it reversed and closing
you know, before it reversed. You know,
you got to understand how these candles
form, right? Because it's a red candle.
So, generally with a red candle, you
don't necessarily You can. You can trade
down and then trade up. If that happened
in this case, again, I didn't look at
the I mean, I
at the 1-second chart to see exactly how
it formed, but my inclination is that it
since it's a red candle, it probably
traded up first, came back down, tested
the low, and then closed lower. Then
obviously the next bar comes in, but
even if,
okay?
Even if you got short here,
maybe it it did tick down first. I I I
doubt it, but if it did,
came back up here, stopped you out, you
got your next exhaustion print here. And
you would have been short again right
here, okay? To catch this move back down
from 91.25
down to your bullish exhaustion print
right here.
Right? Where it moves all the way back
up to about 25 again. So, it's goes from
25 down to 75, but realistically, you're
looking to get out here around 95. So,
it's 25 cents
and then another 25 cents right here.
That's quick 50 cents
in, you know, from 5:10 to about 5:30.
Now, I just want to talk about this
delta that was taking place here. You
know, a strong negative delta in this
bar.
-87. Here, it was -23.
So, we're dropping. Aggressive sellers
coming in. You can see the imbalance,
the imbalance, the imbalance.
And you just trade a little bit lower.
You got your exhaustion print down here
of one. And you got your positive delta.
You got your buying imbalance.
Okay, so you can see the reversal
starting to form in real time there.
And once it does, trade higher.
You know, the next bar just jumps up
from, you know, 90 all the way up to 91
10.
So, this bar is about 20 cents right
here.
And then, close to another
[clears throat] 20 cents in that bar.
Um
There's any
more. I'm sure there's a few.
These two. Okay, you know, I want to put
these in here.
Get long right here.
Just sort of goes sideways, and
eventually comes out, stops you out.
Fine.
Same thing here.
Gets you into the trade.
But
following bar stops you out.
Okay. I mean, you know, your risk is
defined here and here.
And then you just saw on the previous
two trades, you know, over 25 points, 25
ticks. You know, this is about 10 ticks
here. This is about 11 ticks here. But
you got it back over the next two
trades. I mean, you don't need to like
scale up or do anything. This is also a
short that didn't work out here. But
this one you got pretty tight tighter
stop cuz it's a smallish bar.
Um you're short here. You get stopped
out there. And you just wait for the
next trade, right? I mean, it's
This, you know, even if you, you know,
here's a trade. Okay?
Here's your short here.
This is where you're getting short at,
right here. Okay? So,
call it 92
58 or something. You know, your stop's
up here.
This is 90
Look at that, 9250
90 I'll call it 9245. 9245.
Down to 92.
All the way down to This is
This is at 60 down here, but it didn't
hit 60 over here.
This is
45 ticks from from here to here.
Then another 40 ticks here. So, you
know, even though
you you had these other trades here
where you know, that was a loser.
This was
These two were losing trades.
You know, you're losing 10 to 11 ticks,
10 to 11 ticks. This one you're losing
about nine ticks.
You know,
you just had this trade here that was 40
almost 80 points, 80 ticks. So, you you
lost 30 ticks on three trades. That's
fine. I mean, you can live with that
when your trade is coming in, you know,
making 25, 30, 40, 50 ticks.
Um
this one here.
Take this one that would have stopped
you out cuz got in here before it closed
down here. Okay, fine. You know, again,
you're risking about 10 to 11 ticks
there.
Then you catch the one big beautiful
trade there. You know, some small
shorts. You know, this was a long here.
Again, now this is around midnight. You
know, Asia was open. But generally
speaking, you know, I I
worked at JP Morgan in Singapore for
almost a decade.
And I know that when it's US holiday,
UK spring holiday,
um and you have them in the fall also
with Labor Day sort of coincides with
the the fall bank holiday.
Is
the guys in Singapore and Japan and in
and Hong Kong are are
you know, we're we're just taking it
easy. We're just kicking it back. It's a
day that we bank.
What I mean by that is uh
We come into the office
just to just to sort of
catch up on everything, paperwork,
whatever. We're not naturally looking to
do a lot of trading, but here's a short
you would have gotten on. This would
have stopped you out.
This was a small little winner here.
You're getting long right here. Again,
your stop is just below this green line.
If you're getting long at 75
you know,
you're getting out on this reversal
signal here.
Somewhere around 90,
that's 15 cents. Again, you know, that's
at at midnight Chicago time.
Um
Yeah. So, you know, even though it's
it's a holiday, there are still trades.
You know, as as we took you through
these trades.
Um
You know, but just realize, you know,
it's a holiday. You don't have to trade.
You know, so I know traders like to to
live have this fantasy in their head
that oh, the market's open. I got to be
involved. No. You know, when the big
traders are out that's a
that's probably a good time for you to
take off as well.
Um you know, last thing you want to do
is on a slow market. This gets to the
psychology of trading. On a slow market
if you have the itch, the urge to trade,
you're not going to get the moves. I
mean, I don't want to say you're not
going to. Chances are you're not going
to. I I've seen days where it's holidays
like either in the US or UK and and you
do get some big moves, but those are
rare, okay? You can't treat a holiday as
a normal day. I mean, it's it sounds
stupid. I mean, cuz it should be common
sense, but I do see a lot of traders
sort of forcing the issue.
Right? Like over Christmas holidays.
That that time between Christmas and New
Years. People
you know, take the time off. You know,
no one you know, it's it's a holiday.
You spend time with your family. Do some
other stuff. Recharge yourself rather
than try to sit here. And yeah, while
you're you're right on this move here
it's going in your favor. It's just
super dead quiet.
That you know, your normal move probably
isn't going to happen. I mean in crude
you should be getting real regular nice
price movements, but
you know, on a holiday you just don't.
So, again, you know, it sounds pretty
basic, but again, I just want to
reiterate that and just sort of get it
out for you guys.
You get a little video out for you just
to for those of you that want to sort of
follow up on on holidays
with the
exhaustion entry model. So, enjoy the
rest of your Memorial Day and I'll catch
you guys later. Take care.